are you wearing the chanel boots yeah
i am marie antoinette l woods
wonder woman each of these leading
ladies knows how to use fashion to make
an impression
the actors writers and directors get
some credit but we can't forget about
the incredible costume designers who use
clothing to immerse us in spectacular
cinematic worlds
whether it's fantasy recreating the past
or illustrating a character's distinct
style
these wardrobe wizards use costumes to
reflect a character's individuality
and make them relatable the shape color
and texture a designer chooses creates a
bold visual statement
and demonstrates everything from a
character's personal growth
to where the story might take us next
let's explore some of the amazing
costumes from our favorite films
and discover how they contribute to such
marvelous storytelling
now tell me where did you get that
beautiful cape
great movie costumes can make us feel
like we're being transported into
another reality
the present can be transformed into the
past the future
your jacket is now dry even an alternate
universe
and there's no better place to start
discussing the importance of wardrobe
than with 1939's
gone with the wind which uses costume
design to transport us to america
in 1861. costume designer walter
plunkett
not only created one of the most
accurate costume portrayals of the south
during the civil war but also used
scarlett o'hara's wardrobe to
demonstrate the restrictions
and expectations of the time when mammy
chides scarlett for her dress
we immediately get the sense that she's
someone who rises up against social
restrictions
her dress at the barbecue is different
from those worn by the other women
with covered shoulders and chests the
green ribbon symbolizes one of scarlet's
flaws
envy but her stubbornness also endears
us towards her
as if i couldn't get a better bold metal
maiden bridges in titanic
the 1912 fashion reflects the transition
from traditional to modern styles
costume designer deborah lynn scott won
an oscar for her work
and one of her biggest accomplishments
was being able to realistically
illustrate the differences between the
first class and third class
passengers when it came to rose and her
peers there was a focus on lace and
beating
for the lower class passengers there are
diverse immigrants wearing clothing from
irish italian
eastern european and scandinavian
backgrounds
what does she know about misery
accurately portraying culture
is a challenge for designers but making
some creative tweaks to historical
accuracy
is not necessarily a bad thing memoirs
of a geisha
is set in early 20th century japan
designer colleen atwood mixed modern
silhouettes with her research on kimonos
while many point out that atwood's
kimonos are different from traditional
kimonos
it's done on purpose so they would be
more impactful for the film
who is responsible for this many films
use this technique of modernizing
historical wardrobes so that today's
audience can relate to a story
and its characters the costumes from
2013's the great gatsby
aren't very historically accurate for
example designer catherine martin
decided not to flatten women's chests
which was popular in the 20s but the
modern elements she chose to include
create a distinct tone allowing us to
see ourselves
in these characters
this is absolutely where you live my
dearest one jacqueline duran designed
the costumes for 2019's little women
and won an oscar for her portrayal of
popular 1860s fashion
but she still took liberties with the
dresses the characters wore
skipping hoops and bodices so that the
clothing was less restrictive
in order to reflect the inner strength
and independence of the women on the
screen
duran also designed the costumes for
atonement keira knightley's green gown
is iconic but definitely shows more skin
than was appropriate in 1935.
another of duran's films anna karenina
is set in the 1870s
but inspired by images from the 1850s
duran wanted a balance of strict
and romantic fashions because that's
what she felt better represented the
character
well how do i look
just as fashion reflects the time period
of a film
it also sets the movie's tone and gives
us a sense of what's to come
milena cannonero designed the costumes
for the grand budapest hotel
and used rich colors mainly purple red
pink and yellow to create a fairy tale
environment with uniforms
far different from what you'd expect
hotel staff to wear zero's bellhop
uniform is a version of gustav's
concierge uniform which
immediately makes you connect them and
prepares you for the way their fates
intertwine throughout the movie
cananero also perfectly captures wes
anderson's distinct style
reflecting not only the characters in
the film but also the director
you're now going to be officially
interviewed should i go light the candle
first
sir sweeney todd on the other hand
creates a distinctly
grim environment you can only expect bad
things to happen with the dark drab
dirty and gloomy fashions and the pops
of color
actually seem unsettling like wes
anderson's films
tim burton's films have a distinct style
that ties together
daring costumes and sets creating his
own version of the world
in addition to immersing us in a
believable world
costumes have to create believable
characters in 500 days of summer
tom wears warm dark colors like brown
while summer wears cooler colors like
blue
this is made obvious right from the
opening title as the film progresses
their colors start to rub off on each
other tom is surrounded by blue
and summer starts wearing brown sorry um
i just left uh can i once again in
legally blonde
elle woods's wardrobe constantly
reflects her personality
even when her life is changing her
fashion reflects different experiences
but it's distinctly her own sense of
style fashion
sets elle apart from her fellow harvard
students just as it sets willy wonka
apart in the 1971 film
his jacket was not a popular style
making him seem
ahead of his time the color hat and bow
tie are details that make him stand out
from the crowd
and raptured entranced are we ready yes
good
tim burton's alice in wonderland uses
unique fashion typical of a burton
film but it's actually the subtle
additions to alice's wardrobe that best
reflect her character
costume designer colleen atwood used
black decorations on alice's youthful
blue dress to show viewers
that the character is not as childish as
we might think
since fashion can help us get to know a
character it also changes to reflect
character development
in marie antoinette designer melena
cananero
dresses kirsten dunst in youthful
fashions at the beginning but they
become more sophisticated as the
character matures
in titanic rose is dressed in tight
dresses that illustrate confinement but
near the end
she literally rips herself out of her
restrictive wardrobe and her dress
becomes loose
oh stop it mother you'll give yourself a
nosebleed
this is not a game katie's style in mean
girls
changes as she swaps social circles she
begins by not knowing much about fashion
then she becomes a plastic and finally
she finds a happy middle ground
that is a reflection of her and not just
the people she surrounds herself with
you look awesome i know right
the fashion in a film can also
demonstrate a character's extravagance
or
a film's distinctiveness the devil wears
prada
used very expensive fashion that would
have cost over a million dollars if
they'd had to pay for it all
the fashion used is also timeless which
takes a keen eye in a sense for what
will still be fashionable in the future
and it's sort of comical how you think
that you've made a choice that exempts
you from the fashion industry when in
fact
clueless uses trendy outfits to capture
the style of
upper class teenagers designer mona may
also did the costumes for romy and
michelle's high school reunion
and both films have very distinct
aesthetics
that set the film apart and are still
popular
off of today
[Applause]
in birds of prey there are no high-tech
or expensive superhero costumes
but the costumes capture each of the
characters unique personalities with
their strengths in mind
as well as makes it clear that these
women aren't very experienced at saving
anyone
you okay yeah he's gone
of course capturing character becomes a
lot trickier when movies are about real
people
like marie antoinette sure designers
have actual images to look back on
but accuracy definitely faces more
scrutiny
julie weiss designed the costumes for
frida based on real portraits
she also used traditional oaxacan
embroidered tops and colorful beaded
jewelry that were purchased from actual
mexico city street merchants
for jackie the exact historical
references worked out in their favor
natalie portman not only mastered
jackie's unique voice but also
rocked copies of actual outfits worn by
the first lady
he had the most wonderful expression on
his face you know
some films like elizabeth get a lot of
criticism for the costumes not being
accurate
enough but designer alexandra byrne did
outdo herself by copying elizabeth's
exact coronation outfit from a portrait
world building relies heavily on costume
design because
no matter how good a set or story is
it's impossible for a fantasy to be
believable
if the characters look and dress exactly
like us
in lord of the rings over 19 000
costumes were made to create the
characters of middle earth
all of the pieces were made by hand and
even the simplest mesh armor took
three days to make in harry potter the
school uniforms are an important part of
how we view hogwarts
and what makes it different from any
other fancy boarding school
the wizarding world also has its own
witchy style
but it's not so different that we have
trouble believing that magical people
co-exist with
as the muggles say truth will out
yes it's one thing to design incredible
animated wardrobes
but it's another to bring that magic to
life while it may seem like a lot of cgi
goes into making the movies
feel enchanted most of the wardrobes
from favorites like beauty and the beast
and into the woods were made by hand
cinderella's dress
was made of 12 layers of different
colored silk and tulle
and 10 000 swarovski crystals it took
lily james
45 minutes to put it on when it comes to
creating science fiction
or an apocalyptic universe costume
designers have to toe the line between
relatable
and believable styles and what they feel
like the circumstances of the future
will create
in star wars there's a focus on western
and military clothing
and though it's not something any of us
would wear every day
they're simplistic and familiar enough
to be relatable with the blast shield
down i can't even see
how am i supposed to fight your eyes can
deceive you don't
trust them in mad max fury road
extravagant clothing
just wouldn't make much sense the way a
character is styled
allows us into their headspace and tells
us their role in society
the leaders wear more fabric gear and
accessories
while most of the lower class slaves and
fighters do not
superhero films also take it upon
themselves to create
new worlds to create the citizens of
wakanda
black panther's costume designer ruth e
carter studied photos of authentic
african outfits and looked up examples
of body piercing and body art
she mixed together futuristic elements
with traditional african clothes
and high fashion accessories most of the
costumes were created with hand painting
and 3d printing
the costumes match the incredible city
aesthetic that makes wakanda look so
unique
i accept your challenge as cgi
improves costume designers are starting
to use it to enhance costumes
in guardians of the galaxy there is a
mix of real actors plus cgi characters
some of the costumes are computer
designed but there are still a lot of
practical elements used
for example no computer effects are used
on gamora
just makeup and prosthetics meanwhile
captain marvel's costume uses 3d
elements and cgi to seem more powerful
and dynamic
but designer sonia milkovic wanted carol
danvers look to
embrace her gender without being
objectifying
so there was still a lot of time spent
building and creating believable
costumes that weren't just digital
as for wonder woman her costumes
definitely needed the cgi treatment to
look as fluid and functional as they do
but her look still represents older
versions of her character
and diana prince wears a lot of other
costumes with goddess-like elements that
don't rely
on cgi to make them cool which movies
have your absolute favorite costumes
how do you think they contribute to this
story let us know your thoughts in the
comments down below
and hey don't forget to hit that button
if you enjoyed this video
then subscribe to our channel for more
thanks for watching